anyone's allowed to respond to any way
that they want what's your feeling about
this
Trump election um it's not a hard week
and you know I made a joke when our show
first premiered like that Trump so first
of all our first episode features a rap
about my best friend in the show's
broken and it it's just you know the
jugman were like really proud of it
wait a minute just back up a little bit
it's about her sorry her broken it's
broken
Brooke you have to like watch the first
episode but yes I diagnosed her with a
broken she just wasn't doing that well
in relationship I see God when writing
it we were like you know what like women
men are always referring to him is like
we don't really get to own it and claim
it as our own and then president dick
talks about grabbing and he just stole
our entire path under right but you're
not it you're mad at Trump because she
stole your thunder I was that was before
he was president now I'm mad that he's
president so you did
[Music]
you do a thing with your friend where
the two of you you do a comedy routine
together sort of for fun would you is
that fair to say it's more like we just
talked in our vagina voices like we just
develop look this is you and your friend
you you gave that area of your body
voices and personalities yeah it started
just in terms of like talking about how
our vaginas might rebuff a guy so we'd
be like you know and he tried to step to
me what kind of voice is that part of
the conversation
you